[Music]
foreign
this is a very clear case of if this
object didn't get help it would
deteriorate even more over time
I'm Sarah director of conservation at
Center art studio and today I'm going to
walk you through how we restore a
polychrome sculpture of Saint Paul from
1720.
the work that we're doing on St Paul is
a full restoration this piece was very
dirty it also was flaking so the paint
was lifting and cupping it was actively
in a state of degradation where any kind
of Transport or touching or handling of
this piece would potentially risk
incurring additional damage
this piece belongs to a private
collector in New York City
we know that it's Latin Colonial it is
carved from a single piece of wood and
it's been heated and gilded
the book and the sword are always
symbolic of Saint Paul so when you see
those attributes on a sculpture or in a
painting or work of art you can know the
fat Saint is meant to be safe off
the writing on the book it almost looks
like an early depiction of music not as
nudes
that wouldn't be a typical attribute of
the book that Saint Paul holds it stands
out in this case as being a little bit
unusual
you never know exactly what conditions
something it's been exposed to so there
are certain climatic conditions that can
cause flaking
we also know that because the paint is
flaking in particular areas that means
that the entire sculpture is at risk
the first step of this restoration is to
consolidate the plaking piece we can't
clean the object until it's stabilized
obviously it's an object that has
history but it is nicely carved
it had beautiful crackle lines and the
colors were vibrant so if we remediate
those issues we're going to end up with
a very beautiful object
the book was heavily blinking it also it
is just a big open horizontal plane
that's going to accumulate a lot of dirt
we're going to do the same consolidation
process to the feet
so the first thing we have to do is
apply this resin
is a completely stable conservation
grade resin it's dissolved in a solvent
we apply it with a brush and we apply it
on the surface and also we tried to get
under the flakes and into the cracks of
the sculpture as best we can
capillary action helps us here so this
liquid flows under the chips and like
into the recesses of the sculpture and
the sculpture soaks it up
that allows the flakes to become
flexible and we can kind of push them
down back into position
and then over the course of a few hours
the solvent that that resin was
dissolved in evaporates but the resin
remains and so that stabilizes the piece
we use the solvent to simultaneously
remove that resin and also clean the
dirt off just that one solvent removes
all those layers and just gets us down
to the original paint layer
there were felt pads on the bottom of
the vase the sculpture they also can be
places where dirt gets chopped so these
were not really even necessary so we
just removed them and we'll clean under
those areas and just start fresh
now that the piece has been cleaned we
are going to move on to filling the
cracks and areas of loss we use a
water-based putty to fill in any missing
areas on the figure on the robe on the
base it goes on in sort of a liquid
viscous state it basically is replacing
the missing gesso
we overfill a little bit because it is
so easily reversible and reducible that
you're going to get a more even fill if
you slightly overfill the area of loss
you know we put it on it looks a little
wrong but then we can use water to
reduce these spills we also can use a
very fine grit stain paper
you want to be very careful that you're
using a grit that's not going to cause
any damage to the painted original
painted surface
now that the sculpture has been filled
we'll use brushes and conservation
paints to in paint those spells and
match as best we can the original paint
that would have been in those places
we use conservation paints when we're
doing in-hating and in heating is simply
applying paint to fills this is
different than over painting which would
be painting over original surfaces
it's really a process of color matching
to the surrounding area
I approach when I'm doing it is to
typically do washes of color so I'll put
a color on a fill and then I'll be like
okay this needs to simultaneously be
more red green yellow and brown
so then I'll like add those colors to my
brush and then I'll do it again so it's
like a series of washes that accumulate
to create like the desired color it goes
from looking like a slightly broken
object in the state of repair to looking
like a complete object quite quickly
once all that in painting happens so
that transition is very satisfying to
see it
all the areas are stabilized and filled
and color matched correctly
I think we did a very good job at making
it be a more complete object
foreign
we apply shellac to the sculpture we
apply it with a brush all over the whole
sculpture and allow it to dry after the
final coat is applied to the sculpture
we'll wipe it with a cloth buff it and
make sure that there's no surface dust
this illustration took a few weeks for
us to complete
this piece needed to be conserved
because of the state of degradation that
it was in
I'm very satisfied with this restoration
a lot of time went into it
I'm very happy with how the whole
project turned out I'm really it's
always very satisfying to be able to not
only stop damage but prevent future
damage from happening on an object
it just makes us feel like we are
helping extend the longevity of a work
of art through the work that we do
[Music]
thank you